in his first political speech since
leaving the white house former president
donald trump is reasserting his grip on
the republican party mr trump closed out
the annual conservative meeting known as
cpac last night in orlando
he repeated the false claim that the
presidential election was stolen from
him and he offered no remorse for the
assault on the capitol
by his supporters he stopped short of
announcing a
2024 run but strongly hinted that he's
not done with politics
we will take back the house we will win
the senate
and then a republican president
will make a triumphant return to the
white house
who who who will that be i wonder
that former republican president also
attacked by name
other republicans who have denounced him
and who voted to impeach
or convict him republican senator rick
scott is a former governor of florida
he's chairman of the national republican
senatorial committee
which supports gop senate candidates
senator good morning thank you for being
with us
we appreciate it as tony just mentioned
good morning the former president again
falsely claimed that he won the election
you have said you accept the pres you
accept the presidential election results
how does the republican party move
forward if you're still arguing
about the election results sure first i
want to thank jay i think it's great
that we're getting another vaccine out
nope
everybody can get their vaccine as
quickly as possible we get back
everybody get back to school and get
this economy going again
you know i i had the opportunity to go
to cpac last week and i put a memo out
last week to
republican activists donors party
leaders about this this republican civil
war has been canceled we
are not going to look backwards we are
going to go forward we know that there's
a lot of things that by administration
are doing that americans
republican never counted independent
don't believe in we don't believe in
open borders we don't believe in
closed schools we don't believe in men
women women sports
so we're going to focus on the fact
we're going to focus on the issues and
going forward
we're going to have i think we're going
to have a great uh 22
we're going to bring everybody together
uh the republicans are going to take the
house the senate and i believe
uh the former president's right we're
going to win the white house in 24.
you say senator the republican uh civil
war has been canceled but
vice president mike pence congressman
liz cheney were noticeably absent
from cpac the president directly
attacked republicans who voted
against him in the impeachment trials in
the impeachment trial
how do you have a unified party how is
the civil war canceled if that is going
on in public
well if you here's here's the way the
party works get out of washington
the farther you get away from washington
you know the more united
united the republicans are um and and
what
biden is our unifier pelosi and schumer
i mean
this this idea that we're going to open
our borders we're going to not we're
going to peas
uh dictators we're going to you know go
back to the old way we did business with
china
um you know these killing the keystone
pipeline that is unifying republicans
around the country
like what's going on in washington is
not what's going on around in the
country
what's going on around the country
people say i want my job i want my kids
back in school i want to fund the law
enforcement i want to save community
i want a strong military i want a
country that stands up to dictators
that's what
and that's what the republican party is
going to do and the democrats are doing
the opposite
yeah senator you're right that
washington is a different animal than
the rest of the country but
those senators and members of congress
who are calling out the president
they're representing or trying to
represent what they think the viewpoint
is in their states
so i want to get one more question here
in on the divide that we're seeing mitch
mcconnell uh
senate majority leader until this past
election
has uh called president trump morally
and practically responsible
for the assault on the capital former
president trump for his part calls mitch
mcconnell a political hack that seems
like an untenable situation for
republicans how do you go forward
you he talks to the people out out in
florida go around florida they're not
talking about
what what what these party leaders are
saying what they're talking about is
what's good for my family they're
talking about issues when i ran for
governor i talked about the issues
that's how i won that's how we're going
to win in 22 we're going to talk about
the things that people care about jobs
education law enforcement
you know that's what they care about
they're not they don't they're not
talking about what party leaders are
are you know they're you know anything
they're saying about each other that's
why
the civil war is absolutely cancelled
we're going we're not going backwards
we're going to go forward and win in 22.
to your point senator uh one of the
things that people are worried about is
getting some relief from the coronavirus
the democrats
are pushing a coveted relief bill that
you oppose you say it's too big
isn't it just important to get relief
out to people as quickly as possible
well look this is somebody's money we
need to do the right things let's let's
help people
lost their job let's let's help the
businesses that are struggling
but less than one percent of this is
about the vaccine i mean
what do we what do we start would you
all talk about you know all morning is
johnson johnson less than one percent of
this bill is about the vaccine it's
about a
a bridge for for chuck schumer a tunnel
for nancy pelosi
i mean this is about this is about
paying back liberal politicians
it's not about getting our country back
to normal again let's focus on the
vaccine let's focus on testing let's
focus on
helping people lost their job let's
focus on getting our businesses going
again
that's not what this bill does so it's
really disappointing and it's not part
it's very partisan it's not a bipartisan
bill it's not they didn't come to the
republic and say let's work together
every bill we did last year we allocated
4.5
trillion dollars was bipartisan there's
still a trillion dollars we haven't
spent
yeah senator i hear that as a as a point
of political messaging
i think the democrats are aware that it
would appear that you guys are holding
up something that
as you point out is not all about those
unemployed americans but would help
about 10 million
unemployed americans so what do you do
politically here to what would you say
to them this morning
about why you're saying no when this
could help them
come talk to us we want we want to help
people but we're not going to
go waste americans money we have 27
trillion dollars worth of debt you see
interest rates are going up
inflation is coming back it's caused
because of government spending so let's
do the right thing for the american
public
let's help people that lost their job
let's help our small businesses
let's make sure we have vaccines let's
make sure we have testing
but wasting americans money when you
know somebody's gonna have to pay that
back you will your kids or your
grandkids
that doesn't make any money that's not
the way washington should work
all right senator rick scott thank you
very much for being with us this morning
we appreciate it